là
mais là mademoiselle messieurs bonjour
je sais bien que ce soit encore une fois
sans effet mais je ne peux m'empêcher le
site est d'emblée le bilan sanglant
vraiment meurtrier de quatre jours de
week-end sur les routes
212 tué 5500 blessés pour 3500 accidents
chaque jour de vacances 53 français
souvent des enfants ont donc trouvé la
mort ont laissé leur vie sur une route
c'est à celle au camp pour ne rien
ajouter la côte d'azur a vécu une nuit
d'angoissé certains témoins disent même
une nuit d'épouvanté plusieurs milliers
d'hommes lutte en ce moment encore
contre des incendies que le mistral
attise le feu a pris naissance hier au
début de l'après-midi brutalement et en
des points différents de sorte que les
enquêteurs vont s'efforcer de dire s'il
s'agit d'un incendie habituel en cette
saison où des incendies provoqués en
attendant de savoir si une main à
allumer ces gigantesques feux le point
tout de suite avec françois corner
depuis la nerthe à l'ouest de marseille
jusqu'à aise à l'est de nice sur trois
départements les bouches du rhône le var
et les alpes-maritimes 10000 20000
hectares où plus on ne sait pas encore
avec exactitude de forêts et de pinèdes
ont jusqu'à présent été ravagée en corse
mille hectares de pinède et de maquis de
bastia ajaccio en passant par corte sur
la côte est ont été transformés en un
désert calcinés par 15 incendie attisé
par le mistral après les bouches du
rhône dans le var c'est à 14h30 hier que
tout a commencé
l'alertent au feu été donnée près de
plan de la tour à dix kilomètres de
sainte maxime
le mistral soufflait alors à 120
kilomètres/heure attisées par le mistral
lincendie descendez rapidement vers
grimaud et sainte-maxime dès 21h 5000
hectares de forêt étaient calcinés vous
pouvez distingué en noir sur cette carte
les régions les plus ravagées par ces
incendies
le littoral méditerranéen et la corse où
l'on a frôlé là-bas la catastrophe
les flammes sont pratiquement venu
lécher un dépôt d'explosifs à valrose
aux alentours de marseille à la nerthe
l'incendié a pu être maîtrisé vers 4
ce matin par contre toujours sous
l'effet du mistral qui s'est remise à
souffler lincendie de plan-de-la-tour a
repris avec intensité ce matin les
flammes avance dans deux directions vers
la martelle et vers les issambres à
l'aube trois canadair ont repris leur
ronde au-dessus du massif des maures et
des verser à chacun de leur passage des
tonnes d'eau que le mistral
malheureusement répand un peu au hasard
pour combattre le front de ces incendies
tous les effectifs de pompiers ont été
mobilisés dans le var on a même fait
venir ceux de la drôme du rom de la
loire du vaucluse et de l'hérault bien
qu'aucun bilan officiel n'ait pu encore
être dressés on estime pour l'instant à
plus de dix mille le nombre des campeurs
ayant provisoirement fuient leur terme
en dépit des conditions propices pour la
propagation des incendies le mistral qui
souffle dans le midi et pour lequel la
météo ne se montre pas optimistes pour
les heures à venir
on se demande en effet si un certain
nombre de ces foyers n'ont pas une
origine criminelle
vous l'avez entendu le vent et le
mauvais temps gêne les opérations de
secours
en tout cas les vacanciers de l'alpe
d'huez et de chamrousse n'en reviennent
pas il grelotte en cette saison et il
regarde la neige en une journée le
thermomètre est tombé là bas de 40
degrés il paraît que le temps devrait
s'améliorer dès demain et vous aurez bon
week-end en tout cas je vous le souhaite
il y avait un conseil des ministres
pardon à l'elysée ce matin dans quelques
minutes nous aurons françois henri de
virieu en direct il attend les
explications de monsieur léo hamon le
porte parole du gouvernement
cet après midi monsieur pompidou
présidera un conseil restreint consacré
aux affaires européennes c'est un
conseil intéressant puisqu'il se réunit
après le sommet franco-allemand de
bonnes et après la visite à paris hier
vous en souvenez de seurre à l'aide du
latium
de plus ce matin anthony barber qui est
le monsieur marché commun à londres
prévoit des négociations très dures avec
les six car il y aura dit il des
intérêts à défendre bien sûr à concilier
et a partagé la première grande
difficulté que rencontrent en ce moment
le gouvernement risque c'est la première
grève nationale des dockers depuis 44
ans
s'il ne craignait pas de provoquer la
colère des syndicalistes monsieur vis
seraient tentés de proclamer l'état
d'urgence qui permettrait à la troupe
d'intervenir et de remplacer les
grévistes
pour l'angleterre qui est une île comme
chacun sait cette grève est un coup dur
l'économie dépend de son commerce
extérieur comme vale expliqué stéphane
paoli
oui c'est 47 mille hommes grève risque
de mettre gravement en péril l'économie
britannique qui dépend plus que tout
autre de son commerce extérieur
l'étranger fourni à la grande bretagne
la presque totalité de ses besoins en
matières premières et la moitié des
produits alimentaires qui lui sont
nécessaires d'où l'intense activité qui
règne habituellement sur les docks du
port de londres aujourd'hui tout cela
est paralysé et si la grève se prolonge
elle portera atteinte à la balance des
paiements qui pour la première fois
depuis des années était excédentaire
mais il ya d'autres conséquences
la panique dans la population qui craint
un risque de pénurie alimentaire
alors qu'en fait il n'existe pas dans
l'immédiate les réserves dans les
magasins et les entrepôts frigorifiques
sont suffisantes pour couvrir une
consommation normale pendant plusieurs
semaines
l'industrie a également 40 jours le
fonctionnement sûr et en revanche
l'industrie automobile d'exportation et
les journaux dont la moitié sont vendus
à l'étranger seront certainement les
premiers secteurs touchés par une
prolongation du conflit
on comprend mieux alors et dangers que
court en ce moment la liste erling qui
s'est affaibli hier dès l'annoncé de la
grève alors michel tardieu vous êtes en
ce moment la bourse de paris
quelles conséquences pourrait avoir
cette situation sur la monnaie anglaise
bien il ya eu déjà un effet immédiat
hier la cub livre a perdu quinze points
sur le marché des changes c'est beaucoup
et la banque d'angleterre qui n'est
pourtant pas très riche actuellement a
dû puiser dans ses réserves de devises
des doigts pour soutenir sa monnaie et
la situation est grave
la visite à l'heure et chacun ne peut
s'empêcher de se rappeler qu'en 1966
lorsqu'il y avait eu la grève des marins
britanniques qui a vu les mêmes
résultats c'est-à-dire le blocage
complet du commerce extérieur et bien
cette grève avait joué un rôle important
dans la dévaluation de la livre de 1967
elle avait pris une part importante dans
cette manipulation monétaire et beaucoup
de gens ne peuvent s'empêcher de faire
une comparaison
tout le monde se dit que si la situation
continue comme elle est actuellement en
le têt et bien d'une part les ménagères
vont avoir tendance à faire des achats
de précaution comme on dit ce que ras
pour effet immédiat de faire monter les
prix
d'autre part en même temps que les prix
des matières animaux des produits
alimentaires montrent on est bien
l'industrie aura tendance à s'arrêter
et si l'industrie s'arrête et les
anglais ne pourront plus exporter
vous l'avez dit en balance des paiements
aller mieux mais depuis février leur
balance commerciale est déficitaire et
l'angleterre est bien incapable de se
payer le luxe d'un arrêt de ses
exportations
hier michel tardieu la banque fédérale
d'allemagne avait décidé d'abaisser à
partir d'aujourd'hui le taux de l'is
quand deux sets et demi à 7% pour
essayer tout au moins de freiner la
surchauffe de l'économie ouest allemande
alors mettons pas en train de courir
vers un été chaud sur le plan monétaire
merci je crois même qu'on pourrait dire
régine deux choses sont presque un peu
lié
les allemands ont pris des risques en la
baissant leurs taux des secondes parce
que c'est une mesure qui risque de
relancer leurs activités intérieures qui
est déjà trop rapide mais il espère par
cette baisse du taux d'escompté
décourager les capitaux étrangers de
venir se placer en allemagne parce
qu'ils toucheront moins d'argent et
c'est une façon de résister un petit peu
aux mouvements spéculatifs qui vont
probablement se déclarer avec la
faiblesse de la livre anglaise
la situation est d'autant plus grave
qu'il y avait deux monnaies malades
jusqu'ici le dollar depuis de longues
années et la lire italienne depuis
quelques mois
si la livre elle aussi donne des signes
de faiblesse très brutaux et bien les
états unis qui jusqu'ici avait soutenu
la livre auront du mal à la fois à
défendre lors de l'arrêt à soutenir la
livre anglaise donc le dollar risque de
se retrouver pris dans une situation
très difficile pour lui c'est
probablement pourquoi donc les allemands
prennent des mesures comme celle d'hier
et aussi pourquoi monsieur giscard
d'estaing laisse en place toutes les
mesures de contrôle des changes qui
concerne le franc parce qu'en cas de
coup de torchon comme on dit sur les
marchés monétaires est bien la france
pour être à même de mieux résister elle
aussi merci michel tardieu nous vous
retrouvons tout à l'heure n'est ce pas
en direct depuis la bourse de paris
d'autres informations internationales
indochine on commence à se persuader que
toute solution négociée et politique de
la sphère passe par l'accord de la chine
qui sortit maintenant de la révolution
culturelle est en train de revenir sur
la scène internationale l'importance de
son rôle
paris l'a souligné à plusieurs reprises
déjà
d'où l'intérêt de l'accueil séjour en
chine de monsieur andré bettencourt qui
était il ya quelques jours dans le
bureau de mao tsé toung et de schwann là
les entretiens que monsieur bettencourt
ministre délégué auprès du premier
ministre a eu avec monsieur tout en laye
se sont déroulées dans une atmosphère
cordiale pour confirmer le renouveau des
relations franco chinoises
monsieur tron lie premier ministre et 3e
dignitaires du régime chinois s'est
rendu personnellement pour la première
fois depuis 1964 à la réception donnée à
l'ambassade de france à pékin lors de la
commémoration du 14 juillet
l'instauration des relations
diplomatiques entre la chine et la
france en 1964 n'avait pas conduit à des
résultats particulier sur le plan
politique
bien que sur le plan économique on avait
noté un léger accroissement des échanges
commerciaux entre les deux pays
il semble que la visite de monsieur
bettencourt renforcera ses relations
selon le souhait des deux parties alors
que la délégation française après s'être
entretenu avec le président mao tse
dessous poursuit sa visite dans les
provinces chinoises
on envisage la possibilité d'une visite
en france d'une haute personnalité
chinoise dans un avenir assez proche
certains disent qu'il pourrait s'agir de
monsieur chevénement et le premier
ministre chinois hui main en tout cas
monsieur andré bettencourt a beaucoup de
choses à raconter dès mercredi prochain
lorsqu'il rentrera à paris a prague le
journal du parti roues des travaux s'en
prend encore une fois la légende
d'alexandre doccheck andy miele vos dix
mille moore qui se réduisent d'ailleurs
à une dizaine de mots qui font des
double check je le cite un communiste
sans principe sans courage est prêt à
toutes les compromissions pourtant ce
communiste n'aurait pas été exclu du
parti écrit rue des pavots s'il avait
fait son autocritique critique et s'il
avait reconnu que les russes avaient eu
raison d'intervenir à prague
moyen-orient il se passe décidément
quelque chose entre diplomates
ce qui explique ces considère bull ces
consultations quelque chose peut-être de
positif et de nouveau en tout cas que
les quatre grands qui se concertent à
new york devrait bientôt proposer ou
imposées au pays du proche orient qu'ils
inspirent ou qu'ils aident le général
moshe dayan est moins optimiste
il craint que le prochain round ne se
déroule pas
autour de la table de négociations mais
sur le champ de bataille et dans les
airs pour les débuts de la quatrième
année depuis la guerre des six jours
moshe dayan promet lui aussi des larmes
et du sang en italie du sud un problème
de régionalisation a provoqué cette nuit
des incidents très violents et des
heurts entre la police et la population
de reggio de calabre
cette population protesté parce que sa
ville reggio n'avait pas été choisie
comme capitale de la région un mort une
soixantaine de blessés revenant en
france pour dire que monsieur chaban
delmas a envoyé hier un télégramme pour
rendre hommage à monsieur joseph sauty
un des fondateurs vous le savez du
syndicalisme chrétien
les obsèques de celui qu'on appelait
simplement familièrement lepers outils
ont été célébrées hier à lens françois
cau oui il est également le président de
la confédération française des
travailleurs chrétiens depuis novembre
1964 il ya des mineurs et hier les
mineurs lui ont rendu un dernier hommage
moi si joseph sauty il était père de
neuf enfants
outre les préfet du pas de calais du
nord outre les représentants des
charbonnages de france de nombreux
syndicalistes cftc cgt cfdt et fo ont
assisté à ses obsèques
mademoiselle dinesh secrétaire d'état
l'action sociale représentait le
gouvernement
il fut l'homme d'action at elle dit qui
a profondément marqué le monde du
travail et contribuer à l'évolution
sociale du pays
joseph sauty est mort d'une maladie
professionnelle
une maladie qui frappe surtout les
mineurs la silicose
il avait 64 ans
pour également précisé que notre
confrère du canard enchaîné morvan le
bec ce qui est mort l'âge de 59 ans la
semaine dernière au cours d'un reportage
au prince il sera inhumé demain au
cimetière de nantes hier télé soir vous
présenter la crise l'air france 180 une
berline spacieuse et paraît-il puissante
aujourd'hui voici la citroën gs six
chevaux 4 portes 5 places
traction avant elle a plusieurs qualités
en particulier son confort la citroën gs
sera une des vedettes du prochain salon
de l'auto naturellement nous en
reparlerons si un ami vous demander un
jour de call arrondissement est partie
l'arc de triomphe
je comprendrais volontiers votre
embarras répond l'arc de triomphe et la
place de l'étoile qui servent depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années à délimiter
les arrondissements les quartiers de
paris sont situés à la fois dans le
viiie le 16e et le xviie arrondissement
tout est donc une question de
perspective
michel drucker les sports nous allons
commencer naturellement avec le tour qui
réserve au secteur le problème numéro un
c'est un tour qui est qu'ils aient joué
depuis longtemps d absolument tour de
france et jouer depuis longtemps est
sauf accident le belge eddy merckx
arrivera en vainqueur dimanche prochain
à paris avec une avance considérable sur
ses poursuivants ses poursuivants qui
sont résignés qui court maintenant pour
les places d'honneur il s'agit
maintenant pour eux d'essayer de se
faire remarquer en glanant par-ci par-là
les victoires d'étapes que merckx veut
bien leur laisser
hier c'est un français qui a gagné
christian raymond après une belle
échappée de 40 km vous avez sans doute
suivi l'arrivée en direct
aujourd'hui a lieu la 20e étape elle est
divisée en deux tronçons une première
partie en ligne qui se termine dans
moins d'une heure à bordeaux après 234
kilomètres d'un parcours très plat à
travers les landes et la gironde la
deuxième partie est une épreuve contre
la montre sur 8 km 500 sur le circuit du
lac à bordeaux vous suivrez ces deux
épreuves en direct je voulais 10 à 13
heures 45 la première et vers 17h40 pour
l'étape contre la montre
oui c'est le deuxième états unis il mène
deuxième événement sportif important
l'athlétisme le match allemagne de
l'ouest états unis à la fin de la
première soirée les américains ont 10
points d'avancé 58 à 48 6 victoires
américaines contre quatre allemands
la meilleure performance a été réussi
par le sauteur en longueur allemand
schwartz qui avec un bond de 8 mètres 35
a égalé le record d'europe du soviétique
igor terraube ambitionne je parte
à 29 ans il a une protéine progression
particulièrement rapide puisque l'année
dernière il n'avait pas encore franchi
les huit mètres mais avec un avis loin
voyons deux grands moments de cette
soirée les allemands de l'ouest n'ont
pas connu une première journée
euphorique comme les français il ya une
semaine à colombes ils se sont bien
battus pourtant à stuttgart hier soir
comme en témoigne ce 400 m où l'on peut
voir en action de gauche à droite sur
l'écran
colette chose que smith et j'ordonne
tulle et bien l'allemand jordan 21 ans à
droite
maillot blanc révélation de l'année sur
400 mètres meilleurs spécialistes
européens avec jean claude mallet il a
pris un départ plutôt prudent mais dans
le virage elle voir il change nettement
de cadence jordan entre en tête dans la
ligne droite mais les derniers mètres
vont être terribles
john smith et wayne collett en pleine
accélération
le dépasse alors irrésistiblement à
l'arrivée 45 secondes 1 pour john smith
45 secondes 3 pour colette 45,4 pour
jordan comme d'aller à colombes le 4 x
100 lui est un exercice acrobatique dans
lequel les sprinteurs américains ont
rarement preuve d'habileté
il avait été dominé à colombes par un
remarquable relais français à stuttgart
ils ont été plus heureux mais vous allez
le voir souvent ils ont frôlé la
catastrophe
au départ croquettes maillot sombre pour
les états unis hofmeister pour
l'allemagne regardez-bien croquettes
il manque de trébucher
et le passage avec gaughan est plutôt
laborieux américains et allemands sont à
égalité
la seconde transmission vaughan arc est
meilleur arte 22 ans étudiante
californie havas la longue foulée le
virage dans un style impressionnant
nouveaux passages très critique avec
taylor mais celui ci est beaucoup plus
rapide que l'allemand et galère au bout
de la ligne droite 39 secondes 3 pour le
relais américain 39 secondes 6 pour les
allemands ac au long de la semaine
dernière le relais français avait
réalisé 39 secondes juste contre les
américains merci à l'évidence demande
quel temps à lire les américains quand
ils passeront correctement les témoins
les autres résultats de cette première
partie de ce match herman états unis au
poil allemand birlenbach a gagné avec 20
mètres 35 c'est le nouveau record
d'allemagne au 100 m l'américain volcom
a réussi 10 secondes mais le vent était
favorable au 400 m haies l'américain
ralph man 49 3/10 aux quinze 100 m
morgan met à gagner en 3 minutes 40
secondes 7/10
je vois que sa tête est allemand qui
avait été saluée à mexico venait
d'effacer de l'est à l'ouest et à mexico
il avait pas pu courir car il ne
séjournez pas depuis assez longtemps en
allemagne fédérale c'est dégueulasse ce
soir deuxième partie de ce match
allemagne etats unis cette deuxième
partie comme la première devrait être un
avantage des américains le reportage
avec l'eau de baigneaux en fin de soirée
sur la deuxième chaîne michel douat une
petite question qu aurait pu faire les
athlètes français face aux athlètes
allemands il est difficile de prévoir un
but i'm on peut penser qu'avec la forme
actuelle des athlètes français le score
aurait été peut-être moins brillant car
les athlètes américains vont dominer
nettement les athlètes allemands mais
les français se seraient bien défendu et
il aurait été intéressant de voir
n'allait qui vous le savez a réalisé une
très grande performance à colombes face
aux athlètes américains fait nous nous
verrons cela la semaine prochaine dans
quelques jours puisqu'il y aller
championnat de france et nous verrons
quelle est la forme des athlètes
français tennis l'espagne a facilement
remporté la finale de la zone européenne
trop facilement d'ailleurs les espagnols
ont battu la yougoslavie il mène trois
victoires à zéro avant les deux derniers
simples qui commence cet après midi à
barcelone
santana giesbert temps gagné facilement
le double hier donc hier soir à new york
griffith a battu guerre qui dirait à
droite griffith sa gauche mais c'est
bien griffith ce qui a remporté ce match
en 10 reprises c'est un match des poids
moyens
griffith vous en souvenez sans doute a
détenu le titre mondial de cette
catégorie des poids moyens il en fut
dépossédé par le bel italien nino bienne
venuti
football une information importante qui
concerne le prochain championnat de
france l'as et ajaccio le club corse qui
avait perdu sa place en première
division après les matches de barrage a
été repêché par le groupement des clubs
professionnels
ajaccio fera donc partie des 20 clubs
qui forment vous le savez la prochaine
division professionnelle une division
unique ce repêchage est intervenue après
l'abandon des normands de rouen et
football toujours de photos amusantes
qu'il s'agit de la finale de la coupe du
monde féminin de football féminin qui
est bien l'italie et oui les femmes
s'intéressent de plus en plus au
football la récente la récente ici en
france aussi et la récente coupe du
monde y est sans doute pour quelque
chose voici mademoiselle christensen qui
est une danoise qui salue la foule elle
a remporté avec son équipe cette
première coupe du monde mais je peux
vous dire que dans toutes les salles de
rédaction sportif il y aura de nombreux
amateurs pour suivre ces rencontres
merci michel drucker
en vérité le premier sujet de votre
chronique colonies de vacances et pour
les moustiques
pour lui ces chalets pour les minis pour
les petits enfants de 6 ans parce que
vous savez qu'actuellement les colonies
de vacances sont en pleine activité bien
entendu à travers la france mais il
existe des colonies maternelle c'est à
dire des colonies pour qu'ils
accueillent les enfants de moins de 6
ans et justement nous sommes allé
retrouver des enfants qui partaient pour
ses colonies et qui pour certains se
séparait pour la première fois de leur
mère mais pour aller passer de très
bonnes vacances
moi je prends pas de vacances alors je
voudrais qu'ils ont profité que quand
même que dans paris vous savez il n'y a
pas tellement mais ça ne vous en faites
pas de la partie c'est un peu triste
mais pour son intérêt je préfère vous
voyez les colonies maternelle
ce sont ces colonies de vacances pour
les petits de 4 à 6 presque aussi
ancienne que les colonies de vacances
pour les plus grands elles correspondent
à un besoin évident pour les enfants et
pour les parents
plus les enfants sont jeunes plus ils
ont besoin d espace pour évoluer les
activités de ces vacances sont très
variées mais l'eau reste un élément
attractif de première importance
ces séjours sont organisés par la
fédération française des oeuvres laïques
mais les enfants sont généralement
envoyées par l'intermédiaire des caisses
des écoles ou des comités d'entreprise
car individuellement cela revient
relativement cher compte tenu de
l'importance de l'encadrement
environ une monitrice ou un moniteur des
étudiants ou des jeunes instituteurs
pour quatre ou cinq ans fois l'occasion
pour chacun d'apprendre à vivre en
société et même de prendre quelques
responsabilités
mais on a beau être en vacances
l'emploi du temps est respectée et pas
question d'oublier de son havelid en
avant la sieste quotidienne à quatre ans
la vie familiale est souvent préférable
à la vie de groupe
mais ici tout se passe bien sans drame
les machines ne sont pas trop jeune ses
enfants pour partir en vacances
écoutez même bien sûr il y a des fois
des problèmes mais la plupart de ces
enfants là sont des enfants qui sont
déjà scolarisés si je peux dire ils sont
habitués à aller à l'école maternelle
alors ils ont déjà l'habitude de la
séparation
par conséquent un kit et moment pour eux
n'est pas quelque chose de nouveau
évidemment nous en avons quand même
parmi eux pour qui la séparation est une
chose délicate lors nous essayons dé
sécuriser eu évidemment le soir il
couche avec leur petit tour
nous leur laissons leur valise premier
soir nous les défusions enfants et
dorment avec leur affaire à côté d'eux
et quand ils ont parcouru lieux qu'ils
ont
visiter la propriété qu'ils ont fait
comme on dit fait une confiance déjà
dans les lieux qu'ils nous connaissent
un peu alors on commet là nous vit dans
les valises qu'ils acceptent et la
sécurité est assurée les philatélistes
se mettent aussi en vacances et la
rubrique de jacqueline caux va s'en fait
l'écho avec notamment une exposition
évoquant la chasse et la pêche à nouan
le fuzelier jolie petite localité du
loir-et-cher s'est tenue l'exposition
chapek 70 sigle qui signifie que cette
exposition fut consacrée à la chasse et
la pêche
la philatélie qui n'ignore aucun des
sujets qui peuvent attirer à elle le
grand public propose sur ces deux thèmes
un nombre impressionnant de timbres de
tous pays en cette année européenne de
la protection et de la conservation de
la nature
il est bon de se familiariser avec les
différentes espèces qui vivent dans nos
champs nos forêts où nous rivière pour
distinguer celles réellement nuisibles
de celle que l'on appelle le jeunes
philatélistes tout comme l'amateur
chevronnés trouvera à travers les lignes
est postales et les cartes maximum
consacré à la chasse ou la pêche un
vaste champ de recherche par là même un
plaisir sans cesse renouvelé augmenté de
l'agrément de voir paraître constamment
des nouveautés sur ces deux thèmes
internationaux
notre administration postale nous
annonce à partir du 21 septembre
la mise en vente d'un timbre de la série
d' usage courant de postes aériennes
représentant mermoz et saint-exupéry la
liste des timbres 0 nez s'allonge
on sait qu'il ya plus de 300 vignettes
qui comporte dans leur dessein alors
légende des erreurs historiques
géographiques ou autre et immédiatement
on songe au timbre de saint kitts nevis
qui représente christophe colomb
regardant de son avis à la côte
américaine avec une longue vue alors
qu'on sait très bien que cet instrument
n'a été découvert qu'à siècle plus tard
très récemment aussi il ya eu un timbre
du congo
représentant une annonciation de
botticelli portait en légende assomption
et aujourd'hui c'est la république du
yémen fertile en émission consacrée aux
oeuvres des grands maîtres de la
peinture qui nous propose une perle
voici ce qu'il en est a des tomes de la
série consacrée aux oeuvres qu'abrite le
musée des offices à florence représente
le célèbre portrait du duc d'urbain
frédéric de monter filtre or le perdre
piero della francesca a également fait
le portrait de l'épousé du dic et le
graveur du thème lui a inscrit sous le
portrait du duc le nom de la duchesse
batista sort d'un voile un petit jeu
supplémentaire de vacances
amusez-vous à rechercher les timbres aux
aironi des émissions nouvelles qui elle
ne comporte pas d'erreur tout au moins
jusqu'à présent on est pas aperçu le feu
sont celles qui ont été émises par la
grande bretagne et les pays attachés à
la couronne britannique pour célébrer le
centenaire de la mort de charles dickens
fils d'un petit fonctionnaire dickens
n'acquittent à portsmouth très jeune il
dut travailler en usine et salle marca
pour la vie destinée par la suite au
barreau il abandonna la jurisprudence
pour la littérature excellent reporter
il se fit remarquer notamment par ses
scènes de la vie anglaise et ses
premiers romans mis en relief son talent
humoristique
ce fut le cas avec monsieur picwic avec
mika aubert personnage pompeux et
pittoresque nous devons également à
dickens dans cette oeuvre des pages
inoubliables consacré à l'enfance d'une
exceptionnelle vérité de même dans
oliver twist où transparaît l'obsession
de sa jeunesse malheureuse et de ses
humiliant souvenir
et qui n'a pas été ému par la touchante
petit neil du magasin d'antiquités et
les misères des héros des grandes
espérances mais dickens fut aussi un
auteur de romans historiques comme nous
le rappelle barnaby rush et l'histoire
des deux villes qui dénonce les maux
dont souffre la société anglaise du
xixème siècle
fut-il un contestataire de son époque
en tout cas un souffle véhément de
révolte sociale souffle dans son
christmas carol observateurs impitoyable
dickens le saura également en dépeignant
martin füssel vite ce monstre d'égoïsme
on doit aux grands romanciers une
histoire d'angleterre également pour les
enfants et encore bien d'autres oeuvres
que les timbres poste n'ont pas encore
évoqué lorsque charles dickens
s'éteindra miné par de dures épreuves
morales et physiques
andré maurois rapporte qu'un petit
garçon demande à monsieur dickens est
mort est ce que le père noël va mourir
aussi
et bien michel tardieu vous nous avait
déjà entretenu de la situation
préoccupante en angleterre pouvez-vous
nous tracer le climat de la bourse de
paris aujourd'hui la situation est plus
détendu à la bourse de paris
les boursiers vont peut-être dire encore
une fois que paris suis moins bien new
york à la hausse qu'à la baisse
parce que wall street hier s'est
ressaisie les américains selon qu'ils
considèrent l'actualité économique
immédiate ou les promesses
d'amélioration qu'on leur fait et bien
vendent ou achètent et les fluctuations
en dents-de-scie continue donc wall
street était bon hier on s'attendait que
paris soit en hausse assez vive
aujourd'hui
en fait la séance est encore soutenu
soutenu mais peut-être un peu moins
qu'hier un peu plus indécises qui est il
ya cependant de nombreux points de
fermeté aux étrangères il faut signaler
la fermeté des allemandes
parce que la baisse du taux d'escompté a
été posée industriel allemand qui
s'attendaient plutôt à des resserrements
de crédit une bonne surprise et la
bourse a monté en allemagne et les
valeurs allemandes montrent aujourd'hui
à paris les bourses et français bien sûr
s'intéresse à tous ces problèmes
monétaires
mais il ya aussi des informations
industrielles françaises qui retiennent
leur attention et notamment
l'affirmation faite ce matin par notre
confrère les échos selon laquelle le
gouvernement va finalement accepté le
rachat de bull bull mais elle court en
ce moment 90 apte à 86 va finalement
accepté le rachat de bulles par la
société américaine honeywell vous
souvenez comme onenet la general
electric propriétaire de bull annoncé la
vente de tout son département
informatique un spécialiste de
l'informatique
honeywell et general electric devenait
actionnaire de noël à cette occasion un
certain nombre de partisans des
ordinateurs bleu blanc rouge avait dit
reprenons bull ou plus exactement que
l'état les sociétés françaises
intéressées reprenne bull et marion bull
avec la c2 i la société française
ordinateur les entreprises françaises
qui étaient concernés qui auraient été
concernés par cette opération comme
thomson csf n'étaient pas chaudes du
tout pour ce mariage elle faisait
remarquer que le repli de general
electric le géant américain est bien
montré à l'évidence que la construction
d'ordinateurs coûte très très cher
finalement les réalités financières
semblent l'avoir emporté
et elles ont amené le gouvernement à
accepter la solution américaine avec des
conditions disent les échos mais à
l'accepter corner dans un autre secteur
pas très éloigné l'informatique
le téléphone est bien une solution
française a presque prévenu cette fois
c'est une filiale de la cge qui
s'appelle la compagnie industrielle des
communications site ses hits et qui a
pris une participation de 16 % dans la
société française des téléphones
ericsson l'acei t semble-t-il espérait
prendre une participation plus
importante mais la société ericsson de
suède
la mère des téléphones ericsson de
france pense que le téléphone est une
bonne affaire en france où les besoins
comme chacun sait sont très considérable
finalement elle a conservé la majorité
dans sa filiale
la prise de participation de la cité
dans les téléphones ericsson sa compagne
d'accords techniques et de sociétés
rationalisent leurs productions et
développent leurs études communes dans
tous les secteurs qui les intéressent
elles vont constituer désormais le plus
gros groupe du marché français dans le
domaine des téléphones devant les
filiales du géant américain itt était
voilà les informations qui font parler
les boursiers les informations qui
repose sur des fêtes mais il ya aussi
toujours les bruits de elie aboud bourse
persistant depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est celui selon lequel selon lequel
bsn verriez bien connu et célèbre depuis
une certaine affaire saint gobain bsn
bsn et perrier serait sur le point de se
rapprocher on dit même que les deux
groupes auraient complètement serait
complètement tombés d'accord sur le
principe
le ce rapprochement mais que les
modalités seraient difficiles à mettre
au point
ça n'est pas étonnant parce que ni
monsieur antoine riboud le président de
bsn ni monsieur gustave levens le
président de périers n'ont l'habitude de
sous-estimer la valeur de ce qu'ils
vendent ou de surestimer la valeur de ce
qu'ils achètent donc là encore une
affaire à suivre sur le marché de l'or
vous voyez les cours en ce moment et
bien malgré les divers mou
monétaire on reste d'un calme olympien
là-bas et les pièces s'effrite encore un
petit peu aujourd'hui l'opinel lui je
crois est toujours en hausse oui il
n'est pas 100 59 10 contre 158 50 y est
il continue donc à se raffermir et c'est
la bourse de paris à vous france vérité
merci michel tardieu au revoir bonne
journée à tous
elle